what would happen if you traveled to  Uranus well strap in and get comfortable  because it would take you at least 10  years to reach this ice Giant and if  scientists didn't launch within the  window of a planetary alignment you  could be drifting the cosmos for much  longer and come on the meter's running  this trip would cost four trillion  dollars I got my bag packed after  finding this story on morning Brew  morning Brew is a free daily newsletter  in five minutes get the latest news in  business finance and Tech on Earth or  anywhere else it only takes 15 seconds  to subscribe and it's completely free  hey 4 million subscribers can't be wrong  click on the link below and find out get  access to the best stories online ones  that'll inspire you to ask